وبعد اعلان النيه روسيا تعليق مشاركتها في
المعاهده الروسيه لخفض الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه القى تصريح الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الضوء على القوات النوويه
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه وبحسب الاعلام
الروسي فان الكميه الدقيقه للاسلحه
النوويه التي في حوزه روسيا هي من بين
اسرار الدوله فبموجب معاهده ستار ثلاثه
فانه بحلول الخامس من فبراير 2018 كان
اجمالي قدره روسيا النوويه هو
527 وحده لنشر الصواريخ البالستيه العابره
للقارات والصواريخ الباليستيه الغواصه
والقذفات الثقيله والف 1444 وحده للرؤوس
الحربيه للصواريخ الباليستيه العابره
للقارات والصواريخ الباليستيه وكذلك
للرؤوس الحربيه النوويه
المحتسبه كقاذفات ثقيله وسبعمائه وتسعين
وحده للقاذفات القابله وغير القابله للنشر
والصواريخ الباليستيه العابره للقارات
والاس القبيله وغير القابله للنشر اما
بالنسبه للبيانات الصادره عن معهد
ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث السلام فاعتبارا
مي يناير 2022 امتلكت روسيا
5977 راسا نوويا بما في ذلك
1588 تم نشرها على مركبات اطلاق جاهزه
للقتال والفين 289 في حاله توقف